I thought they were a big victory
against one of the co-leaders going into
this round Jennifer you take us through
this very tense game
both manage our time really poorly and
at some point something happened we
didn't have time and then the game ended
the social version of this game
yeah so here's the critical moment so I
think at this point we were wondering
and you both were having close to 10
minutes with a lot of moves in this
position with an hour on our class
because there's nothing critical happen
until this point and queen 25 was an
option as well did you consider this
movie yeah but it doesn't work G6
so or according to F5 sorry
I used to have been the right move oh no
I didn't like taking only five I just
didn't feel comfortable doing that it's
too much happening on that files too
many pieces that is true and you are
perfectly right because after F5 you
have to force okay there is no way I can
calculate this yeah absolutely and you
played Bishop to E3 yeah that is the
safer option how did you assess the
position Oh I thought that five was a
mistake I thought she has to take only
three
phone
is ruined but I have a bishop I have the
file
definitely some conversation yeah
foreign
a lot of pressure on F7 don't worry
about the computer
I've covered my net I can't make it at
some point go F5 take with the E Pawn I
don't know like I thought
this can be quite dangerous for her and
I think actually the engines are just
finding some sort of very uh concrete
lines Knight F6 if you go to F3 Knight
G6 and things of this nature change uh
the structure but
she played F5 and allowed you to get at
least momentarily heruk on H7 yeah even
here she has to take only four
yes and then I think Bishop C5
and then yeah take because there are
some lines where she can try to trap my
like E4 Knight F6 and then my knight on
H4 like she can go G5 my knight is trap
that's why I had Bishop C5 so I can take
only seven yeah so why not can you but I
thought even here I should be doing fine
because the position opened and I have
two Bishops and the pawn on e4 could
become a liability in the future yeah
she has to have something concrete
because the long term like this has to
be really nice for me absolutely and it
does seem like that's the case as well
Rook takes A7 she played yeah this is
already losing for her because
everything is hanging down I probably
have many ways of playing here not so
much I think uh you did find the most
precise way Rook takes C8 and queen to
uh G6 after that I thought of a good
victory for you how does that feel how
does it feel to take uh Jennifer you out
in this game
um yeah it feels good it's my first
victory of the tournament I'm very
unhappy with the way I'm playing I just
don't trust myself can't make any
decisions I think it stems from not
playing a lot of chats taking long
breaks
but yeah it's an important Victory she's
a very dangerous player the year she won
she had 10 out of 11 so when she goes on
the streak she becomes Unstoppable so
yeah I think this was crucial for me
guys
oh our congratulations start to have a
wonderful game a nervy game because of
the time trouble but uh very
entertaining to call and I think it's
time to gain your confidence back I mean
you're really doing well in this
tournament don't say anymore not good I
said you're my inspiration every time I
come here I get such positive feedback
more often yeah
and as we prepare ourselves for a break
over here we just wanted to